BLM was never fighting the system
BLM is the system
it was never in opposition they
pretended they were in opposition we're
going to fight the cops we're gonna burn
down the courthouses we're going to
attack the economic system by looting a
bunch of sneaker stores and jewelry
stores
but then what would happen
the most powerful interests in the
country would bail them out
the current Vice President of the United
States bailed these people out of jail
bailed the criminals the rioters out of
jail staffers for Joe Biden bailed these
people out of jail
the district attorneys just wouldn't
prosecute a lot of them
maybe a slap on the wrist in many cases
just charges dismissed
because BLM is serving a purpose in the
political order